yeah alrighty well mother nature has
given away all this great sunshine and
incredibly warm weather as we close out
november we've got some cool 40s but
also some low 50s downtown on the strip
centennial hills still right in those
low 50s here are your headlines we're
going to stay extra warm in those upper
70s when we should be in 60 degrees for
the last day of november i know you want
to wear your sweaters and your boots and
instead we're still in short sleeves and
barely long sleeves in the morning we'll
stay dry and above normal next week we
get some clouds some breezy winds and
some 60s but no rain and really not too
cold the more long nights we get down
into the 40s and every once in a while
we touch on some 30s for morning lows
but next week i think we'll be a little
cooler in the morning today we're going
for 77. that's almost the record high
for today 79 is the record 60 is where
we should be there's snow across the
great lakes and the northeast and
there's more rain in the pacific
northwest while high pressure rules our
weather and a weak cold front that will
deliver a little northeast breeze at
times today and tomorrow that will
help cool us off a little bit but poor
folks in washington state boy flooding
problems those continue for them while
sunny warm dry conditions continue for
us so we'll start out really with some
southwest breezes very light and then
they'll turn more to the northeast this
afternoon so we welcome december 73 so
temps start to slide tomorrow and then
right into the low 70s to get into the
weekend next week there come the clouds
some breezes and 60s so again not as
normal as we should be but we're getting
closer